the migrant camp was full days ago but
more people are arriving in groups
pitching their tents and waiting for
something although few seem to know
exactly what the facilities in a small
sports complex could never have coped
with this number of people and it's
getting pretty miserable here now smelly
everyone is coughing it's cold and it's
due to rain Leticia and their daughter
Moline who was just three are now living
outside on the street they say it's
better than inside the camp a few of the
migrants appear to have joined this
Caravan heading for the United States
with any knowledge of asylum law but
they are preparing banners for a march
to the border this weekend asking for
mercy and the entry of being poor and
from the country where there is no work
just doesn't qualify El Salvadorian
stand a chance because gang violence is
so bad they're on Durin's like Carlos
don't though he's just hoping that
someone somewhere give him a chance to
change his life and his families as well
we are wearing what what the people say
what what another country you know
offered to us possible Canada we don't
know possible Mexico Tijuana is a great
city to work they paid really well here
we are waiting well what what person of
what country can offer something to us
that we're working only or all that we
wanna do is work
there have been moves to the board
offense in the last few days they say
they just want to knock on the door of
the United States and say they're here
President Trump has mobilized his
military in u.s. helicopters and keep a
vigilant eye but the Mexican authorities
aren't taking things like me either it's
pretty calm but they're fully prepared
to stop a sudden rush to defense
migrants are only about a hundred meters
or so away from the United States border
but they're being prevented from moving
now by riot police's riot police all
around us here and pretty much all the
rows around are closed as well what
they're going to do we don't know
they've left the camp but staying here
is not much of an option either they try
and make a point I think that they're
here and they want to be listened to the
whole camp is due here on Sunday hoping
that they can at least begin the asylum
process regardless of the outcome half
of the caravan is made up of children in
the thousands of miles from home living
rough it's pretty scary
Stewart Ramsey Sky News Tier one